J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, ravi de vous retrouver. On s'était quittés avec l'entretien de Joe Wolfe début février.
On parlait de son parcours et de ses problèmes d'addiction.
On passe maintenant à une tout autre thématique puisqu'on va parler aujourd'hui d'Europe avec l'eurodéputé Philippe Lamberts, qui est coprésident du groupe des Verts au Parlement européen.
Vous le savez, les élections approchent. Si vous êtes français, évidemment, il y a les élections européennes, mais ici en Belgique, on va bientôt connaître les élections fédérales et régionales le même jour.
C'est pour ça que j'ai pu enregistrer ce mois-ci trois interviews avec différents politiciens belges. Et vous l'avez sans doute remarqué, il y a eu un trou dans la parution des épisodes il y a deux semaines.
Bon, je sais que c'est pas tout à fait rare avec Septante Minutes Avec, mais c'était pas prévu du tout. Je vous expliquerai pourquoi à la fin de cet épisode.
J'ai pu enregistrer cette interview-ci dans les studios du Parlement européen, ici à Bruxelles. On a parlé de sujets importants comme l'austérité, la guerre et l'énergie.
Et je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute. C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être rejoint aujourd'hui par Philippe Lamberts. Bonjour Philippe.
Bonjour.
Philippe Lamberts, vous êtes membre du Parlement européen au sein du groupe des Verts depuis 2009. Vous êtes devenu coprésident en 2014.
Vous avez été réélu, donc, à deux reprises. Vous avez été tête de liste pour Ecolo aux élections européennes à plusieurs reprises et vous ne vous représenterez plus.
Non.
On va en parler. Tout d'abord, merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation.
Avec plaisir.
On va aborder de nombreuses questions, beaucoup de réformes, une situation géopolitique particulière, un contexte économique très particulier également, beaucoup d'enjeux pour ces prochaines élections européennes.
Premier sujet qu'on peut aborder, un accord qui a été conclu entre les États membres et la Commission européenne
et le Parlement européen, qui va avoir encore l'occasion de le bloquer, mais accord au sujet des nouvelles règles budgétaires qui étaient vieilles de trente ans,
qu'il faut un petit peu les assouplir pour permettre notamment d'investir dans les domaines comme le climat, la défense, la transition numérique, le vieillissement de la population,
mais surtout, surtout, bien affermir les règles du fameux déficit maximum de trois pour cent et un taux de soixante pour cent maximum de dette publique.
Comment est-ce que vous voyez ces règles ? Le Parlement va avoir peut-être l'occasion de les bloquer.
Ah, il va avoir l'occasion. Maintenant, est-ce qu'il va la saisir, c'est autre chose.
Voilà, voilà.
Vous avez dû écouter le ministre Vincent Van Peteghem, qui négociait pour le Conseil, à mon avis, parce que quand on parle de règles plus flexibles, en fait, au moins neuf États membres-
Oui
...vont se retrouver en fait plus contraints par les nouvelles règles que par les anciennes. Donc, je pense que c'est un abus de langage, pour le dire gentiment.
Oui, oui, j'ai repris les termes-
Oui, oui, j'ai bien compris. J'ai bien compris, mais en réalité, ces règles sont une camisole de force qui a une forme un peu différente que la camisole de force précédente, mais ça reste une camisole de force.
Et ça n'est pas parce qu'à la limite, on met un beau badge Investissement dessus qu'il y a la place dans cette camisole de force pour faire des investissements.
Oui, c'est-
Donc c'est en fait un non-sens absolu. Il faut quand même bien réaliser que
oui, bien sûr, dans une union monétaire qui n'est pas véritablement une fédération budgétaire, c'est-à-dire avec un État central qui dispose d'un budget et du pouvoir de lever l'impôt, ce qui est le cas de la zone euro,
il faut des règles budgétaires.
Encore faut-il que ces règles budgétaires fassent sens économiquement parlant. Alors, point de départ, on a écrit dans les traités, c'est quand même
un texte de portée constitutionnelle, des valeurs de référence qui sont que les déficits ne peuvent pas dépasser trois pour cent du PIB et la dette, le stock de dette ne peut pas dépasser soixante pour cent du PIB.
Ces deux valeurs n'ont aucune, aucune, aucune base scientifique.
Mh. C'est-
Ça correspondait à peu près aux valeurs moyennes au moment où on a conclu ça. Mais donc, il faut d'abord se rendre compte qu'on a mis dans des textes juridiques-
Mh
...des valeurs de référence qui n'ont-
Arbitraires
...complètement arbitraires.
Mais qui sont, voilà, les sacro-saints chiffres, le sacro-saint trente pour cent-
Ben sacro-saint, ça dépend pour qui.
Ben voilà, voilà, mais historiquement, historiquement, aux yeux du traité de Maastricht-
Bien sûr.
Historiquement, celui qui-
Et alors, l'histoire, c'est que-
Philippe Lamberts, est-ce qu'on se dirige avec ce nouvel accord vers un retour à l'austérité ?
Bien sûr.
Oui.
Bien sûr. D'ailleurs, il suffit d'écouter la réaction de Alexia Bertrand, qui, aux dernières nouvelles, est quand même ministre des Budgets-
Libérale, oui
...et qui annonce que, ben, l'effort budgétaire pour la Belgique, ça va être entre cinq et six milliards par an pour les années qui viennent.
Oui, oui.
Au moins, elle, elle ment pas.
Mh mh.
Dans un contexte électoral en Belgique plus qu'européen, puisque c'est également les élections fédérales et régionales où tous les partis annoncent évidemment des promesses, des-
Ah, mais aucune d'entre elles ne pourra être réalisée.
Oui, oui.
Aucune.
C'est un contexte assez particulier, oui.
Et donc on est dans une espèce de théâtre d'ombres où on-
Quand j'interviewais-
...veut faire croire que, et ça sera juste pas possible.
Quand j'interviewais Jean-Luc Crucke la semaine dernière, à chaque fois, il évitait de dire qu'il allait falloir investir et il expliquait qu'il allait falloir réformer, mieux s'organiser-
Bien sûr
...pour que tout puisse fonctionner mieux.
Bien sûr.
Par magie.
Ça fait combien d'années que vous entendez peut-être de votre côté, que moi, j'entends, dans ma vie business, avant d'être député européen, que mon épouse entend comme enseignante,
comme des amis entendent comme infirmières : il va falloir faire plus avec moins.
Mh mh. Mh mh.
Mais les gars, enfin, je veux dire, à un moment, il faut revenir dans le monde réel. Allez expliquer aux Ukrainiens- Qu'il va falloir reconquérir l'Ukraine, mais avec moins de moyens financiers et moins de moyens militaires.
Oui, oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Et donc tout ça, c'est évidemment de la fumisterie. C'est parce qu'on ne veut pas reconnaître ce qui est vrai et ce qui est vrai est établi notamment par une étude que nous avons commanditée.
C'est que rien que pour la transition écologique, les investissements supplémentaires à faire seront de l'ordre de trois cent soixante milliards d'euros par an pour l'Union européenne, dont deux tiers d'investissements publics.
Oui, bien sûr, une partie doit venir du privé, c'est évident, mais le gros doit venir du public. Et je vous parle bien d'investissements incrémentaux, c'est-à-dire la couche qu'il faut rajouter pour qu'on y arrive.
D'accord ? Et donc comment-- alors bien sûr, je suis d'accord avec l'idée qu'une partie de ces investissements publics doivent être financés par des taxes.
Autrement dit, c'est clair qu'il y a aujourd'hui des francs-tireurs ou des passagers clandestins dans nos sociétés. Ce sont les grandes entreprises, ce sont les grands détenteurs de capitaux,
qui en fait, profitent de nos sociétés sans y contribuer leur juste pas.
Donc bien sûr, ils vont devoir le faire. Mais s'imaginer qu'une taxe sur le patrimoine ou que
des impôts plus élevés sur les multinationales vont couvrir les deux cent cinquante milliards à faire pour le secteur public, là, je pense que c'est un peu une vue de l'esprit.
Donc bien sûr, on peut dire : OK, ça va être des taxes plus des économies ailleurs. Mais moi, je vous ai parlé d'investissements supplémentaires exclusivement pour le climat.
Je vous ai pas parlé de la défense, je vous ai pas parlé du vieillissement, je vous ai pas parlé de la recherche. Je vous ai pas parlé de plein de choses qui sont des besoins qui sont insuffisamment satisfaits.
Alors bien sûr qu'il va falloir
trouver des manières pour la dépense publique d'être plus efficace.
Et c'est vrai qu'on a tous en tête des exemples comme par exemple en France, le quoi qu'il en coûte ou en Belgique, les subsides au photovoltaïque ont été bien au-delà de ce qui était économiquement raisonnable et nécessaire.
Donc là, on a gaspillé de l'argent public, c'est évident et il faut arrêter de gaspiller de l'argent public. Mais néanmoins, il n'y a pas à sortir de là.
On va financer ces investissements supplémentaires qui, je le rappelle, sont vitaux. C'est pas des trucs dont on peut se dire : Oh ben si on peut le faire, on le fait.
Enfin, il s'agit de notre survie quoi, de notre survie économique, de notre survie climatique, je dirais même plus de notre survie démocratique.
Donc bien sûr, on va les financer partiellement par l'impôt, très partiellement par des économies ailleurs, mais on va les financer massivement par l'emprunt.
Et ça n'est pas un problème. Et donc ça veut dire que, et c'est pas moi qui le dis, mais Olivier Blanchard, qui est ancien chef économiste du FMI, qui est quand même pas un ultra-gauchiste, qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
Il dit : Si l'Europe fait ce qu'elle doit faire en matière climatique, il faut accepter l'idée que dans les dix à vingt ans qui viennent, le ratio dette sur PIB va augmenter.
Et ça n'est pas grave en soi.
Voilà, mais c'est aussi très culturel puisqu'il y a cette fission, cette fissure historique, culturelle, économique entre les pays de tradition catholique, tradition protestante, par exemple l'Allemagne,
qui n'aime pas du tout l'endettement et qui résiste et qui tire des quatre freins dès que c'est possible, dès qu'on parle d'endettement.
Est-ce que vous avez cette sensation-là quand vous discutez avec vos collègues du Parlement européen, par exemple allemands, que l'endettement n'est pas vu positivement du tout, du tout, du tout ?
C'est plus une affaire gauche-droite qu'une affaire franco-allemande.
Alors, c'est clair que la manière dont l'Allemagne gère ses finances publiques et la manière dont la France gère ses finances publiques n'ont pas grand-chose à voir l'une avec l'autre.
Mais commençons par l'Allemagne.
Ce pays est en état de sous-investissement chronique depuis des décennies. Résultat : ben, moi, je me rappelle de l'époque où on a dû fermer le pont qui traverse le Rhin à Cologne parce que vu le trafic
poids lourd qui roulait dessus, ben, ça avait fragilisé le pont et il fallait un grand entretien.
Sept mille ponts en Allemagne ont besoin de travaux substantiels. Les avions de la Bundeswehr ne volent plus. Enfin, ne volent plus, ne volent pas ce qu'ils devraient voler.
Les réseaux de télécom en Allemagne, mais c'est une blague. Je veux dire, chaque fois qu'on a des conférences Zoom avec des collègues en Allemagne, ils doivent couper la vidéo parce que la bande passante n'y est pas.
Donc c'est bien joli de dire : Regardez, regardez, nos budgets sont en équilibre. Ben oui, si vous faites pas ce qu'il faut, c'est bien gentil, mais alors si vous voulez vraiment des budgets à zéro, ben, suicidez-vous tout de suite.
Je veux dire comme ça, au moins, vous arrêterez de dépenser de l'argent.
Voilà qui est radical, oui.
Mais oui, mais enfin, je veux dire, à la fin, les budgets, ils sont là pour soutenir la vie. Et c'est quand même la vie qui est première.
D'ailleurs, avec le COVID, on s'en est bien rappelé que ce qui était premier, c'était la vie et que, ben coûte que coûte, il fallait tout faire pour défendre la vie.
Donc, vous défendez une politique d'emprunt sur le long terme, d'endettement.
Oui.
Et vous l'avez dit, une fiscalité qui va taxer plus certains profils. Vous pensez à qui ?
Eh bien, je l'ai dit. Donc les détenteurs de capitaux, et par ailleurs les grandes entreprises. En fait, ce sont les contribuables qui ont le loisir de jouer de la concurrence fiscale entre les États membres.
C'est évidemment pas les PME, c'est évidemment pas les petits contribuables, c'est même évidemment pas les petits détenteurs de capitaux.
C'est ceux qui peuvent se jouer des frontières et aller déplacer, pour les entreprises, leurs profits, pour les grands patrimoines, leur argent,
dans des juridictions où ils sont peu ou pas taxés, en se servant de toutes sortes d'artifices légaux ou parfois moins légaux, de sorte de ne pas contribuer.
Je veux dire, l'Europe est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus riche qu'elle n'était dans les années soixante, quand elle a mis en place la Sécu telle qu'on la connaît.
Donc, comment était-il possible qu'on parvienne à payer les congés payés, l'assurance chômage, l'assurance maladie invalidité dans les années soixante et septante, et aujourd'hui, on saurait plus alors qu'on est plus riche ?
On va dire : Oui, mais elle coûte un peu plus cher. Ça, c'est pas faux. Mais allez, franchement, la question c'est : Est-ce que tout le monde contribue comme il le doit au bien commun ?
Et ma réponse : Non. Nous avons sur cette planète des très très gros passagers clandestins qui en fait sont des prédateurs de cette planète et du vivant et qui en fait, vivent aux crochets de la planète et du vivant quoi.
Et ben, il faut les mettre à contribution.
Vous n'adhérez pas du tout à la théorie du trickle-down. Vous estimez que...
Mais comme vous le dites, c'est une théorie. C'est même une croyance. Parce que c'est même pas une théorie qui est étayée par quelques résultats.
Je veux dire, la réalité, nous sommes dans une trickle-up economy, c'est-à-dire que la richesse va des pauvres aux riches.
Si on met quelques instants entre parenthèses cet accord qui fait qu'on se dirige vraisemblablement vers une politique d'austérité en Europe.
Je sais que vous avez commandé, auprès de l'Institut Rousseau en France, une série d'études pour savoir quels investissements nous aurions besoin.
Parlez-moi de ça. Qu'est-ce que-- voilà, si on arrive à débloquer les financements nécessaires via l'endettement et via la fiscalité, comme vous l'avez expliqué, où est-ce qu'on investit et comment vis-à-vis du climat notamment ?
Alors, j'ai toujours eu pour tradition de travailler sur base de faits et pas simplement de slogans. Et en effet, nous voulions avoir une idée assez précise des endroits où nous avons un gap d'investissement, secteur par secteur,
et ensuite, à l'intérieur de chaque secteur, distinguer la partie publique et privée.
Et donc c'est une étude assez unique parce qu'il y en a régulièrement qui sortent sur les investissements verts, mais c'est la première qui se fait vraiment en mode bottom up.
C'est-à-dire, on prend le secteur de la construction, bon ben on regarde quels sont les flux d'investissements actuels dans la construction.
Et donc ces flux-là vont devoir être redirigés de manière à ce qu'ils financent la construction verte et pas de la construction classique.
Mais clairement, si on veut rénover le bâti existant, ben il va falloir des investissements supplémentaires.
Et donc là, on chiffre le besoin total d'investissement, on fait la différence avec les investissements déjà prévus et on voit le gap d'investissement nécessaire.
Et on fait ça secteur par secteur et on l'a fait avec un échantillon de huit pays qui représentent septante pour cent de l'économie européenne.
C'était impayable, en tout cas pour nous, de faire l'étude sur vingt-sept pays. Donc, on s'est contenté de huit, mais évidemment des plus gros,
de manière à ce qu'on ait un échantillon représentatif et qu'on puisse raisonnablement extrapoler le résultat.
Et donc la conclusion, c'est ce que je vous ai dit : il faut essentiellement deux point six points de PIB en plus par an, donc trois cent soixante milliards en plus par an.
Ça, c'est pour les sources de financement ?
Non, c'est pour les besoins de financement. Après ça-
Oui
...vous pouvez financer ces investissements, comme je le dis, soit en redirigeant des dépenses actuelles par des taxes, soit par l'emprunt.
Je veux dire, il y a pas de miracle.
Ça, c'est l'income. Mais où va cet argent ? Comment est-ce qu'on l'investit précisément ?
Ah ben ça dépend, ça dépend des secteurs. Si vous prenez le secteur de la mobilité, ben c'est largement des investissements publics pour tout ce qui est des réseaux.
Des infrastructures.
Infrastructures de chemin de fer, infrastructures, euh... ça peut être alors des infrastructures de télécom, de toutes sortes de choses.
Le métro à Bruxelles, par exemple ?
Ben oui, oui. Enfin bon, là, il faut voir si c'est vraiment le meilleur moyen, parce que là aussi, il faut être de bon compte.
Il faut dépenser l'argent public de manière économe.
Mh.
Je veux dire, c'est pas parce qu'on va recourir à l'endettement qu'il faut recourir à un endettement illimité. Et là, si on regarde l'objectif de mobilité, ben il faut voir comment est-ce qu'on le satisfait au mieux.
Et est-ce que le ratio coût-bénéfice, c'est vraiment le métro trois qui donne le meilleur ratio ? Ma compréhension des choses, c'est non.
C'est qu'il y a des options de surface qui permettent en fait d'assurer un meilleur maillage de mobilité à moindre coût.
Et donc il va falloir, connaissant... enfin, de nouveau, les finances publiques, ce n'est pas un trou sans fond. Il y a de la marge d'investissement.
Alors, dans certains pays plus que d'autres. C'est vrai que la Belgique est plus endettée en moyenne que d'autres États de l'Union européenne, mais elle a aussi une richesse nationale qui est importante.
Et on l'a vu avec les bons d'État, directement souscrits par des citoyens belges. Ben visiblement, tant que les citoyens ont confiance en prêtant à l'État, ben y a pas trop de problèmes.
On n'a pas de dépendance vis-à-vis des marchés financiers internationaux, parce qu'en fait, c'est ça qu'il faut éviter. Pourquoi est-ce que le Japon peut se permettre un ratio dette sur PIB de deux cent soixante-trois pour cent ?
Parce qu'essentiellement, le Japon emprunte auprès de ses citoyens.
Mh. Ils ont confiance, oui.
Mais voilà. Et donc, je dis pas qu'il faut arriver à deux cent soixante-trois pour cent, mais vous imaginez, on passerait de nonante à cent dix, on a de quoi faire les investissements, y a pas de problème.
En Belgique, on est déjà au-dessus de cent pour cent. Je pense qu'on est à cent six pour cent.
Bien sûr, mais la Belgique a probablement la capacité de tenir ça sur la durée, pour autant qu'elle ne dépende pas des investisseurs internationaux.
Ou avec les bons d'État, qu'il y a une confiance de la part des citoyens.
Mais c'est vrai que certains États, et je pense à l'Italie, je pense à la Grèce, etc., sont plus contraints.
Mh.
Et donc la puissance publique européenne doit venir en appui. Et c'est ce qu'on a fait avec le plan de relance européen.
En réalité, le plan de relance européen post-COVID, donc NextGen EU, a mobilisé huit cents milliards d'euros pour relancer l'économie et ils ont été alloués en fonction des besoins, pas en fonction des capacités.
Il est financé en fonction de la capacité. Et donc clairement, il y a des États, comme l'Allemagne, comme la Belgique, qui financent probablement plus.
La Belgique, je devrais vérifier, mais en tout cas l'Allemagne, certainement, qui financeront ce plan de relance à concurrence de plus que ce qu'ils n'en reçoivent.
Et l'Italie, ça sera l'inverse. Et c'est ça qui permet alors la solidarité économique européenne, qui permet alors d'assurer que
même les États qui ont objectivement une capacité budgétaire plus faible, vu l'état de leur endettement, eh bien, peuvent néanmoins investir, mais avec l'aide européenne.
Alors, ça doit pas se faire sans contrôle hein, et sans conditions, mais ça peut être dans notre intérêt. Prenons l'exemple de la Grèce, je le disais déjà à l'époque de la crise de l'euro.
La Grèce, en fait, a un potentiel d'énergie renouvelable colossal. Enfin, je veux dire, là-bas, ça souffle tout le temps et ça brille tout le temps.
Parfois, il pleut, mais bon. Et donc le problème... donc la Grèce peut devenir exportatrice nette d'énergie. Ça serait excellent pour la balance des paiements du pays.
Ça serait une autre source que le tourisme pour sa balance des paiements.
Mais pour y arriver, il faut investir. Or, les capacités d'investissement grecques... alors bien sûr, il y a moins de taxes et de patrimoine en Grèce aussi hein, il faut pas rigoler.
Mais s'il y a une assistance européenne à l'investissement, ben en fait, c'est une bonne affaire pour l'Europe aussi,
puisqu'en fait, on augmente notre capacité de production d'énergie au sein de l'Union européenne, c'est-à-dire, on augmente notre indépendance par rapport à des fournisseurs extérieurs et c'est très bon pour notre résilience,
y compris géostratégique. Donc voilà.
Donc une série d'investissements, vous l'avez dit, les infrastructures, par exemple pour la mobilité, ensuite la question de l'énergie-
L'énergie-
Vous donnez l'exemple de la Grèce.
L'énergie, là, il y a beaucoup d'investissements qui sont privés. Par contre, et on le voit bien avec le débat qu'on a en Wallonie maintenant avec le photovoltaïque-
Et le nucléaire.
Il y a des investissements de réseaux-
Mh
...qui sont absolument indispensables. Et là, c'est des investissements publics ou parapublics. Le bâtiment, c'est le sujet qui permet de mieux illustrer-
Avant de passer au bâtiment, l'énergie, quelle est votre position aujourd'hui sur la question du nucléaire, globalement en Europe et en Belgique ?
Puisque c'est une question qui a posé problème aux Verts sur cette législature au fédéral en Belgique.
Ben écoutez, personnellement, moi, j'ai toujours dit : le nucléaire, on n'aurait jamais dû rentrer dedans, mais maintenant qu'on y est, ben il faut au moins utiliser les machines existantes, celles qui sont pas en train de se détraquer.
C'est juste par âge, hein, je veux dire, c'est de la mécanique hein. C'est de la mécanique ce truc. Et donc forcément, toute machine vieillit et on l'a vu avec les pannes à répétition.
Mais les centrales les plus récentes, moi ça me choque pas qu'on les prolonge dix ans de plus. Si c'est ça ou rajouter du fossile, je veux dire, y a pas photo.
Justement, c'est ça qui a été défendu en début de législature. C'est plutôt que-
Allez poser la question à ceux qui défendaient ça. Moi, je sais ce que j'ai toujours défendu. Par contre, pour paraphraser le locataire de l'Élysée : ça coûte un pognon de dingue ce truc.
Et donc, à la fois pour des raisons aujourd'hui, non seulement de pollution et donc 'fin de risques environnementaux, c'est la question des déchets et de risques sécuritaires, ça reste des points vulnérables.
'Fin, en 2001, on a vu qu'on jetait des avions sur des bâtiments et les centrales, ben on peut aussi jeter un avion dessus.
D'accord ? Et non, elles sont pas faites pour résister à un gros porteur qui leur tombe dessus. Non, non, ça marche pas comme ça.
Ce sont des cibles effectivement, géopolitiques, cibles.
Trois : ça devient de moins en moins résilient. Et là, je parle pas seulement de l'âge. Je parle tout simplement de la physique de ce truc.
Ça dégage énormément de chaleur, donc il faut refroidir. Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe lorsqu'on a des périodes de sécheresse ?
Ben y a plus d'eau pour les refroidir.
Donc on a dû en France, une des raisons pour lesquelles EDF a perdu des capacités de production, c'est bien sûr le vieillissement du parc et le manque d'investissement, mais c'est aussi le fait que en période de plein été,
quand les gens font tourner leur air co et tout,
eh bien, le niveau des rivières est beaucoup trop bas que pour refroidir les centrales.
Et quand vous rajoutez à ça alors le coût de construction de nouvelles unités, vous dites : OK, ça va, on a compris quoi.
Faut plus jouer avec ça. Faut plus jouer avec ça. Et c'est d'ailleurs très rigolo parce que les fans du nucléaire, après ça, vont nous parler des petits réacteurs modulaires, etc.
Bon, c'est... Vous savez, on a des petits réacteurs modulaires dans les sous-marins nucléaires, dans les porte-avions nucléaires, etc. D'accord.
Dans les pacemakers.
Oui, mais bon, là, il faut pas rigoler. Mais il y a eu un projet commercial aux États-Unis de SMR, donc de petits réacteurs modulaires, il a été abandonné.
Le business case ne tient pas les gars, il ne tient pas. Et je comprends comme ingénieur, évidemment, la fascination que la maîtrise de la fission nucléaire et peut-être un jour de la fusion d'ailleurs, et ça, c'est encore un autre sujet, peut-
Distant, distant.
Peut exercer.
Très lointain dans le futur, la fusion.
Ben écoutez, quand j'étais diplômé comme ingénieur en quatre-vingt-six, on me disait un prototype dans cinquante ans.
Oui.
On est quarante ans plus tard. Peut-être, je n'en sais rien. Il faut pas se fermer cette avenue-là. Mais c'est de nouveau une question de : où est-ce qu'on met ses œufs ?
Autrement dit, son argent.
Ça reste hypothétique.
Ça reste hypothétique, mais enfin, on peut pas non plus fermer toutes les portes. Et donc là, je suis pas opposé.
Mais honnêtement dit, la fission nucléaire de l'uranium, franchement, on en a fait le tour quoi. Et si on avait une solution pour les déchets, ben on l'aurait déjà.
Enfin, je veux dire, ça fait maintenant combien ? Ça fait soixante ans qu'on a du nucléaire commercial et on n'a toujours pas de solution.
Ça pose une question peut-être plus psychologique, plus une question d'image électorale. Comment est-ce que vous expliquez la résistance à ce changement ?
Puisque quand vous l'expliquez comme ça, plus de vert, plus de renouvelable, ça paraît très séduisant, ça paraît être la solution.
On observe une résistance de la population.
Ben oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr qu'on observe une résistance. Ben d'abord parce qu'il y a une résistance humaine au changement.
Je veux dire, ça, c'est tout à fait naturel. Et puis que sur le papier, si vous raisonnez en termes d'aménagement du territoire, ben c'est évident que le nucléaire présente l'avantage d'être une énergie extrêmement dense, concentrée.
Avec deux usines nucléaires en Belgique, on a fait le truc. Si on veut produire la même quantité d'énergie avec du solaire ou de l'éolien, on couvre beaucoup plus de mètres carrés hein, enfin d'hectares.
D'accord ? Et donc forcément, ça emmerde plus de monde. Donc déjà, ça, c'est un facteur. Si on peut dire : OK, on met ça près du port d'Anvers dans une zone, enfin, on a quand même détruit un village pour ça et on fait pas attention.
Et bon, Tihange, ça, c'est plus en zone périurbaine, mais on se dit : OK, on parque ça là et puis on a la paix, c'est évidemment plus confortable.
Voilà, mais simplement...
Donc ça vous met électoralement dans une position plus compliquée.
Non. Enfin, écoutez, je dis, les Verts défendent depuis qu'on est là un projet de transformation profonde de la société.
C'est pas la situation la plus confortable. Vous savez, je serais beaucoup plus à l'aise dans un projet de société qui consiste à dire, comme beaucoup de nos concurrents,
à nos constituants : Écoutez, vous inquiétez pas, continuez comme avant, on va continuer comme avant et tout va aller.
Donc, on est bien d'accord, ça vous met dans une position électoralement-
Mais pas juste le nucléaire, c'est le projet de transformation écologique.
Bien sûr, oui.
On a fait le choix de porter un projet de transformation de la société qui est en fait absolument nécessaire. Mais enfin, les gens sont pas cons.
Une des raisons pour lesquelles je pense, ça reste difficile de voter écolo, c'est que beaucoup de citoyens et de citoyennes comprennent bien que le projet que portent les écolos est un projet de transformation profonde.
Et naturellement, enfin, si à côté d'un écolo qui vous dit : les gars, il va falloir changer beaucoup de choses, vous avez un type qui dit : ouais, ouais, bon, on a bien le changement climatique, mais grâce à la technologie, on devrait rien changer.
Ce qui est le discours des libéraux, oui.
Un type qui vous dit effort et un type qui vous dit confort, à votre avis, qu'est-ce que vous choisissez ?
Oui, oui.
Vous préférez confort quand même.
Oui. Et quelle solution est-ce que vous apportez alors à ce... Parce que quand vous le présentez comme ça, c'est très fataliste.
Non, je suis pas fataliste du tout. Je reconnais simplement le-
La difficulté.
La difficulté et donc on doit être des bons pédagogues.
Oui.
On doit être les pédagogues de la transformation.
Et comment est-ce que vous appliquez cette pédagogie ?
Ben c'est ce que je fais depuis quinze ans. Regardez comment je le fais ici. Oui voilà. C'est d'expliquer les choses, d'abord de partir des faits et puis alors de construire un... Même pas un plan de transformation parce que
aucun individu n'est capable de présenter un plan de transformation.
Ça serait une construction collective. Tout comme le capitalisme financier dans lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui est une construction sociale, le monde de la transition serait une construction sociale.
Et y a personne, je le dis souvent, les Verts n'ont pas une description précise du monde post-transition et n'ont même pas non plus le GPS pour y arriver.
Ce qu'on a, c'est une boussole. C'est une boussole qui nous indique la direction.
C'est un handicap important dans un contexte électoral puisque
pour prendre par exemple, exemple national-populiste, l'extrême droite peut dépeindre un avenir, peut montrer une, voilà, une photo de à quoi ressemble le monde selon eux. Comment est-ce que c'est le monde demain en mieux ?
Ils arrivent à le dépeindre assez-
Mais non, ils disent le monde demain devrait être comme hier.
Voilà, ils ont leur vision. Ils ont leur vision. La gauche a plus de mal, je trouve, à donner une peinture, une photo très claire du monde de demain au mieux.
Mais parce que c'est juste une imposture intellectuelle-
Bien sûr
de prétendre... on ne peut pas. Je veux dire, ce serait une construction sociale. Par contre, quelle est la boussole ?
Quand je vous dis la boussole, c'est-
Oui
ben nous voulons que nos sociétés soient plus justes, c'est-à-dire que, ben, tout le monde puisse y mener une existence digne et pas seulement certains.
Et ça, on voit bien la différence avec le monde d'aujourd'hui. Je vais dire-
Et le discours des nationaux populistes, oui.
Deux
: pour que cette société soit plus juste, ben il faut qu'elle soit plus durable.
Parce qu'une des conditions de notre existence sur cette planète, c'est de faire en sorte qu'on respecte les limites que la planète nous impose et qu'elle nous impose ça.
D'accord ? Et trois : ça doit être une société plus démocratique, c'est-à-dire une société
qui évacue l'arbitraire,
qui permet en effet que les libertés décrites dans la Déclaration universelle des droits de l'homme soient des libertés réelles et pas formelles, que vous ne craigniez pas pour votre vie parce que vous exprimez des opinions.
Regardez comment ça se passe en Russie. Et ces mêmes nationaux-
On va en parler
populistes sont des idolâtres du régime de Poutine. Et donc voilà. Mais le monde de demain sera ce que nous en ferons.
Et c'est ce flou qui, je pense, est un... ce que nous en ferons. Voilà, c'est pour ça que je parle de flou.
Mais c'est-à-dire que vous avez toute une série de partis qui disent : il faut rien changer.
Oui.
Vous avez des nationaux populistes qui disent : il faut revenir au bon vieux temps.
Mmm-hmm.
Et puis-
Le confort, oui
il y a nous qui disons : ben en fait, le principe de réalité, c'est-à-dire il faut partir du monde réel dans lequel on est aujourd'hui, mais ce monde est en fait insoutenable.
Et donc, si on veut qu'il le devienne, ben il va falloir qu'on se mette en marche. Et je le répète, se dire, vous allez dire, je parle comme Macron-
Oui, je
faut quand même pas faire attention. Mais c'est sûr que si j'ai le choix, je le répète, entre l'effort et le confort, ben naturellement, j'ai envie plutôt le confort.
Mais sauf que j'ai toujours voulu prendre les citoyens pour des adultes, pour des gens intelligents.
Mais là, qu'on est d'accord qu'il y a une difficulté intrinsèque.
Bien sûr.
Beaucoup de pédagogie qui est nécessaire.
Bien sûr, si c'était facile-
Là où-
ça serait déjà fait
là où les nationaux populistes ont une facilité, voilà, presque fondamentale à faire des messages très simplistes et très-
Mais oui, et essentiellement, ils disent : vous êtes en colère, vous avez raison. D'ailleurs—
Oui, c'est ça. On écoute la colère.
on est avec vous contre tous ces oligarques qui décident à votre place.
C'est l'exploitation de la colère, finalement, le national-populisme.
Oui, exactement. Et en fait, le ressort sur lequel nous nous appuyons est l'espoir et le ressort sur lequel l'extrême droite s'appuie, c'est la colère quoi.
C'est pas la même chose.
Mmm-hmm.
Et c'est plus dur.
C'est plus dur, mais bon, moi, j'ai jamais eu peur que—
Et on va—
ce soit plus dur hein.
On va faire la transition avec le deuxième sujet que je voulais aborder avec vous. La question des agriculteurs qui ont récemment manifesté—
Ouais.
à Bruxelles et ailleurs. Donc les agriculteurs se plaignent. La colère.
À juste titre.
Tout le monde les comprend, tout le monde essaye de les récupérer.
Alors, il y en a qui font semblant de comprendre.
Voilà. Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'une partie de ces agriculteurs blâme le Green Deal. Alors, ce n'est pas quelque chose—
Vous en avez entendu ?
Certains discours peuvent—
Non, j'ai entendu, j'ai entendu—
Des politiciens, des—
à des barrages, j'ai entendu Jordan Bardella dire ça.
Voilà.
Mais Jordan Bardella, aux dernières nouvelles, sa profession, c'est pas agriculteur. Donc—
D'accord.
c'est un politicien professionnel.
Ce sont les mots qu'on place dans la bouche des agriculteurs.
Ah !
Oui.
Ça, c'est autre chose. J'ai entendu beaucoup de journalistes dire ça.
Ah, les agriculteurs blâment le Green Deal. Moi, je sais pas, quand je vais à leur rencontre, je sais de quoi ils me parlent.
D'abord du fait qu'économiquement, c'est devenu impossible à vivre. En fait, ces gens sont confrontés à un système économique dans lequel on leur impose leur prix de vente et leur prix d'achat.
Oui. C'est l'offre et la demande.
Oui, mais c'est d'abord ça. Non, c'est pas l'offre et la demande.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a les distributeurs, les hypermarchés, etc. qui—
Qui leur imposent leur prix d'achat.
Bien sûr. Ben donc—
Bien sûr. Et leurs fournisseurs qui leur imposent leurs—
Qui veulent pouvoir offrir aux consommateurs des prix de plus en plus écrasés et qui, du coup, a des conséquences sur—
Attendez, attendez, attendez
les agriculteurs qui se retrouvent dans une situation où ils font du stock et du stock et du stock en attendant peut-être arriver à avoir un prix d'achat où ils atteindront la rentabilité, même parfois en dessous de la rentabilité.
Donc c'est une question de, oui, c'est une question de marché où—
D'abord, d'abord—
l'agriculteur est écrasé.
Je reprends ce que vous avez dit. Les grands distributeurs veulent faire des prix bas pour les gens. Ah ouais ? Depuis quand ?
Depuis quand l'objet social de Carrefour, de Colruyt—
Pour le profit, pardon.
Ah oui, mais c'est pas la même chose, les gars. Et ça, de nouveau, ça montre le biais du discours public.
Mmm-hmm.
On voudrait nous faire croire que l'objet des grandes entreprises multinationales, c'est le bien public. Ça n'est pas vrai.
Leur objet tient en six lettres : EBITDA, qu'on apprend en école de commerce. Les profits avant intérêts, déductions, amortissements et taxes.
Mmm-hmm.
C'est de ça qu'il s'agit. C'est de ça qu'il s'agit et de rien d'autre. Je vous parle des grandes entreprises. Je pense que des entreprises familiales, des PME, c'est encore autre chose.
Mais les grandes entreprises comme celles que j'ai citées, enfin, on a eu toute la controverse Delhaize en Belgique. Enfin, l'objet de Ahold,
qui est quand même cette multinationale, la grande distribution qui est propriétaire de Delhaize, n'est pas le bien public.
C'est d'engraisser, et je suis désolé, je n'ai pas d'autre mot, d'engraisser leurs actionnaires. Parce que plus, ça n'est jamais assez.
Il faut encore plus. D'accord ? Il faut presser le citron. Et le citron, c'est la planète, c'est les gens qui vivent dessus, c'est le vivant hein.
C'est ça le citron. Et on le presse allègrement pour maximiser les profits qu'on peut recueillir. Parce qu'évidemment, si machin a un yacht de cent mètres de long, moi, je dois en avoir un de cent vingt,
avec deux plateformes pour hélicoptère et pas seulement une.
Un type comme Bernard Arnault, je crois que c'était dans Le Monde, il y a quelque temps.
Bruxellois ?
Oui, enfin oui, si on veut hein. Ce type a un jour déclaré qu'il n'aurait de cesse d'être l'homme le plus riche du monde.
C'est une philosophie.
C'est pas une philosophie. Non, non, ça, c'est pas du ressort de la philosophie.
Mmm.
C'est du ressort de la pulsion. C'est pas exactement la même chose.
D'accord.
D'accord ? Mais évidemment, c'est un truc sans fin. Parce que évidemment, pour un Bernard Arnault, il y en a beaucoup d'autres qui disent moi aussi.
Et donc c'est à qui en aura le plus. Et forcément, si vous voulez ça, il faut presser le citron.
Presser le citron.
Sans fin.
Presser les agriculteurs. Mais là où je voulais vous amener, c'est surtout sur le fait que le Green Deal, en fait aujourd'hui, n'est pas en application.
Mais d'une part—
Ne touche pas les agriculteurs
Énormément de législations du Green Deal n'ont pas encore commencé à produire leurs effets. Et ce qui est sûr, c'est que le Green Deal n'a pas su toucher le secteur agricole, puisqu'en fait, chaque fois qu'on s'est approché
du secteur agricole avec le Green Deal, ça a été la levée de boucliers, à commencer par l'adoption de la politique agricole commune lors de cette législature.
Une des raisons d'ailleurs pour lesquelles on a voté contre Ursula von der Leyen à l'origine, c'est qu'on l'avait mise au défi, puisqu'elle nous annonçait le Green Deal et qu'elle voulait pouvoir compter sur les voix des Verts.
On lui avait dit : OK, mais alors prouve-le et donc retire la proposition législative de politique agricole commune déposée par ton prédécesseur Jean-Claude Juncker et aligne-la avec le Green Deal que tu nous annonces.
Et alors, on pourra discuter.
Mh.
Elle n'a pas voulu le faire parce qu'elle avait bien compris que déjà, elle amenait le Green Deal contre la volonté de sa propre famille politique,
mais que alors, toucher à cette vache sacrée, si j'ose dire, qu'est le secteur agricole, et je parle bien de l'agrobusiness hein, parce qu'on parle pas des agriculteurs, on parle de l'agrobusiness.
On parle pas d'agriculteurs bio à petite échelle, on parle du—
Non, non, mais ça, au Parlement européen, la coalition, et c'est une coalition de très longue date entre PPE, Sociaux-démocrates et Libéraux pour adopter une politique agricole commune productiviste et mercantiliste.
Enfin, c'est quand même pour une politique agricole commune dont quatre-vingt pour cent se retrouve dans les poches de vingt pour cent des exploitants agricoles.
Et je ne peux pas les appeler autrement qu'exploitants,
pour pas dire exploiteurs. Donc on voit bien que c'est une politique agricole commune qui est là pour soutenir les gros, les industriels, pas pour soutenir l'agriculture familiale et paysanne, ça n'est absolument pas le cas,
ça n'est absolument pas le cas.
On leur laisse les miettes, on leur laisse les miettes.
On disait il y a un instant : est-ce que les agriculteurs tiennent ce discours ou est-ce qu'on place ce discours dans la bouche des agriculteurs ?
En tout cas, oui.
Ce qui a été vu, en tout cas en Wallonie, c'est qu'il y a cette prise de parole de la ministre qui était interrompue par un agriculteur très en colère.
Oui.
Et on a vu, voilà, en tout cas ce qui semblait être une attribution aux Verts de la problématique.
Oui, mais par quelques-uns. Mais moi je parle avec des représentants du secteur, des patrons de fédérations agricoles.
C'est pas ça qu'ils me disent.
Oui.
Premier truc qu'ils me disent, c'est la question du modèle économique qui est intenable. Parce qu'en fait, un agriculteur, c'est un travailleur indépendant.
Ce qu'il veut, c'est pouvoir gagner sa vie de son travail et en fait c'est impossible, c'est impossible. Et donc il doit dépendre de subsides.
Mais moi j'en connais pas beaucoup d'indépendants qui ont envie, pour leur quotidien, pour leur gagne-pain, de dépendre de subsides.
Vous êtes absolument dépendant.
Oui.
Donc ça va pas.
C'est pas glorieux.
Donc le modèle économique ne va pas.
C'est pas glorieux comme situation.
Mais c'est même pas une question de gloire, c'est une question de dignité.
Oui.
Deux, c'est la bureaucratisation à outrance de leur métier,
c'est-à-dire des règles d'une complexité telle et d'une rigidité telle que, en fait, ils sont comme pris, oui, dans une camisole de force, comme je disais tout à l'heure, où ils ne peuvent plus bouger.
Et là, c'est une évolution plus générale dans la société, on est dans la société du contrôle, du zéro défaut, de la sécurité absolue et donc ça devient la société du contrôle absolu.
Critique qui est souvent attribuée à l'Europe et qui a été reprise par les pro Brexit par exemple, en expliquant qu'il y avait beaucoup de rigidité, beaucoup de—
Oui, oui. Mais ça n'est pas faux. Mais c'est un phénomène qu'on n'observe pas seulement dans le monde agricole. Allez parler à un enseignant post pacte d'excellence, allez parler à une infirmière aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'elle va vous dire ?
Elle va vous dire : Mais moi, je passe mon temps devant l'écran à remplir qu'est-ce qu'on a fait au patient, etc., à cocher des cases quoi.
Mh.
À cocher des cases. Alors c'est très bien, on veut le dossier informatisé du patient, mais il faut l'alimenter évidemment.
Et donc le temps qu'on passe à faire ça, on ne s'occupe pas du patient. Et combien de professionnels, et je vais dire en particulier de professionnels de l'humain ou en l'occurrence les agriculteurs, des professionnels de la nature,
vous disent : En fait, on en finit par être des remplisseurs de fichiers Excel plutôt que de faire le métier qui pour nous, enfin, qu'on avait choisi en étant jeune comme portant du sens pour nous.
Et là, c'est une évolution qui pour moi traduit un truc plus profond dans la société, c'est qu'on n'est plus dans une société de la confiance.
Mh.
On est dans une société de la méfiance et tout ça est un produit d'idéologie néolibérale. Je rappelle quand même que les bases de cette idéologie,
on les trouve dans les théories économiques néoclassiques qui postulent, qui postulent, qui n'observent pas, qui postulent
que vous et moi, nous sommes des homo œconomicus, qu'en fait, la seule chose qui nous motive dans la vie, c'est la maximisation de ce que les économistes appellent notre fonction d'utilité, c'est-à-dire notre plaisir, nos possessions.
D'accord ? Et donc ils postulent que si tous les êtres humains, quelque part, s'enrichissent sans faire attention aux voisins, à la planète, etc., on arrivera à l'optimum général.
C'est une vision anthropologique qui, en fait, essentiellement, dit : l'homme est un loup pour l'homme.
Mh, oui, oui. Néolibérale, oui.
Oui, mais c'est fondamentalement ça.
Mh.
Et ça, c'est un vecteur extraordinairement puissant de destruction de la confiance. La confiance, c'est le contraire. C'est le fait que je peux compter sur l'autre.
Et ça, c'est impensable au sens premier du terme. Un néolibéral ne peut pas penser ça. Et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que pour eux, l'archétype de la relation interpersonnelle, c'est le contrat, c'est le marché.
Oui.
Ça n'est pas la confiance.
Vous preniez l'exemple du pacte pour l'enseignement d'excellence en Belgique. Dans ce cadre-là, en Belgique, on a par exemple un enseignement catholique très important.
Je pense que la majorité des Belges sont passés par là. Donc il y a un certain conservatisme qui est inhérent à ces—
Est-ce que vous croyez que le secteur public n'est pas conservateur ?
Je reste sur mon exemple de l'enseignement où là donc,
le contexte de méfiance, de, on va demander beaucoup aux enseignants, aux enseignantes de suivre une série de méthodologies, de remplir peut-être effectivement des documents, des tableaux Excel.
Là, il n'est pas tellement présent dans un contexte de profit.
Non. Non, mais ça, c'est la bureaucratisation du monde.
Oui.
Y a des gens comme Alain Supiot qui ont écrit là-dessus La tyrannie du chiffre. Il faut mettre du chiffre partout.
Mh.
C'est pas pour autant du profit, mais c'est la tyrannie du chiffre.
C'est-à-dire que c'est un contexte où—
Comment est-ce qu'on fait pour passer ? Parce qu'à la fin, c'est quand même l'argent qui compte. On veut mettre moins dans l'enseignement.
On veut en avoir plus pour son argent. Même chose, on veut mettre moins dans la santé ou alors on veut en avoir plus pour son argent.
Ah, c'est quand même mieux si on peut mettre une infirmière par quinze patients en service de nuit plutôt que deux infirmières par quinze patients.
Mais c'est-à-dire que c'est un contexte où la société de la confiance que vous décriviez va peut-être amener plutôt une inertie.
Ah ouais ?
Si on laisse les enseignants et les enseignantes travailler comme ils ont toujours travaillé, est-ce qu'on va avoir une révolution féministe, une révolution écologique au sein des écoles ?
Mais de nouveau, je vais dire, c'est une question de où on met le curseur. Est-ce qu'il faut dire aux gens : bon ben voilà, l'État vous paye et faites ce que vous voulez.
Non, évidemment que non. Mais entre—
C'est la philosophie très, très présente en Belgique de l'enseignement libre. On laisse—
Mais enfin, qu'il soit libre ou officiel, c'est juste la même chose. Je veux dire, vous êtes un enseignant nommé, vous êtes intouchable, que ce soit dans le catholique ou dans l'officiel.
C'est juste la même chose. Et donc, en effet, sans contrôle, ça va pas. Mais alors, je vais prendre l'exemple des heures dites de coordination.
En fait, il y a cette idée un peu, comment est-ce que je dirais, populiste, véhiculée par beaucoup de ministres de l'Enseignement successifs, mais qui flatte un peu, j'ai envie de dire, des clichés qu'on retrouve dans la société.
Oui, en fait, les enseignants, ils ont choisi la profession pour les congés, en fait. C'est des gros paresseux. Donc on va les faire travailler plus gratuitement.
C'est ça l'idée. Donc on va leur imposer soixante heures de travail collaboratif chaque année. Il y avait déjà—
Beaucoup de burn out.
Plein d'enseignants, plein d'enseignants qui faisaient bien plus que leur boulot. Maintenant que ça devient une obligation, ah ben on va remplir des fichiers Excel.
On va dire : ben voilà, moi, j'ai passé X heures à faire ceci et cela. C'est évidemment matériellement impossible de contrôler la matérialité de ces faits-là.
Donc, on a remplacé du bénévolat par du remplissage de cases. Alors bien sûr, est-ce qu'il y avait des passagers clandestins ?
Mais oui, mais comme dans toute profession. Mais est-ce que c'est le meilleur moyen, est-ce que la bureaucratisation générale est le meilleur moyen de s'attaquer à ça ? Non.
Et c'est comme ça que vous percevez le Pacte pour l'enseignement d'excellence ?
Honnêtement dit, c'est— alors, je suis un peu biaisé parce que je vis dans une famille d'enseignants, mais c'est en effet, moi, le ressenti que j'ai.
Maintenant, je suis pas un professionnel de l'enseignement non plus, mais que finalement, c'est un exercice de cochage de cases quoi.
Donc on a parlé d'agriculture, on a parlé d'enseignement. C'était pas prévu, mais—
Non, ben voilà.
C'est arrivé, voilà. On va malheureusement devoir parler de la guerre. La guerre est là, en Ukraine. L'Ukraine n'est pas dans l'OTAN.
La Commission a pu exercer des pressions sur la Hongrie de Viktor Orbán, qui a pu s'écarter. C'était très mystérieux, hein, cet épisode-là.
S'est écarté, sorti de la pièce.
Non, ouais.
Dites-moi, ça, ça ne—
Il y a deux épisodes hein. Il y a l'épisode du conseil de décembre où Orbán est sorti de la pièce pour ne pas s'opposer à l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine.
C'est très particulier.
Il y a l'épisode de février où, ben il a été contraint de retirer son veto à l'adoption de l'aide de cinquante milliards sur quatre ans à l'égard de l'Ukraine.
Là, c'était plus officiel qu'une sortie de salle.
Oui, mais je pense qu'il a réalisé qu'il était totalement isolé, que même un Robert Fico, qui était Premier ministre slovaque et qui a beaucoup de sympathie pour Orbán, n'était pas prêt à monter au créneau.
Donc, je pense qu'il a compris qu'il était cornérisé.
Donc voilà, il est sorti de la pièce au moment où il était question de l'ouverture aux négociations pour l'entrée de l'Ukraine dans l'Union.
Tout ça va prendre du temps.
Oh oui, ça...
Énormément de temps. Même chose du côté de l'OTAN, où on entend quelques voix en faveur de ça. Joe Biden reste très clair comme quoi c'est sans doute pas l'instant, pas le moment, puisque—
Non.
C'est dans un contexte de guerre—
Absolument pas.
C'est compliqué. Pendant ce temps, la Russie continue à bombarder l'Ukraine. Comment est-ce que vous percevez la situation aujourd'hui, l'évolution du contexte européen avec, voilà, la situation actuelle que connaît l'Ukraine ?
Alors, première chose, au moment où la Russie est passée à la vitesse supérieure en 2022, je rappelle toujours que la guerre en Ukraine a commencé en 2014—
Bien sûr.
Avec l'annexion de la Crimée. Non, mais beaucoup disent : ah, ça fait deux ans de guerre. Ben en fait, non, ça va faire dix ans de guerre.
Donc, au moment où la Russie est passée à la vitesse supérieure, j'avoue que le sursaut européen a été rassurant. C'est-à-dire qu'enfin, on a reconnu que ce que nous disaient les États membres d'Europe centrale et orientale,
sur Poutine était vrai.
Et la Finlande, oui, oui.
Ben oui, enfin, tous ceux qui sont riverains de la Russie,
ils avaient raison. Et donc, c'est cette manière de courtiser Poutine qu'avaient les Premiers ministres ou les présidents allemand, italien et français,
était une erreur géopolitique majeure, absolument majeure, de croire que ce type était quelqu'un d'autre que ce qu'il est quoi.
Oui, il y avait par exemple chez Macron la volonté de faire une espèce d'équivalence ou de—
Ça, c'est le vieux fond.
Pas prendre parti plus pour les Américains que vers la Russie.
C'est le vieux fond antiaméricain français.
Oui, oui.
Et c'est combiné à ce vieux fond qui circule encore beaucoup à Paris que la France est une grande puissance et donc elle parle d'égal à égal avec les États-Unis et avec la Chine, avec la Chine ou la Russie.
On se souvient de—
Évidemment, une fumisterie.
On se souvient de comment s'est passée la discussion entre Nicolas Sarkozy et Vladimir Poutine à l'époque.
Mais oui, mais oui. Il faut lire le bouquin là-dessus de Sylvie Kauffmann, qui est éditorialiste à l'international au Monde.
Elle a écrit un bouquin, je crois que ça s'appelle Les Aveuglés, sur en effet l'aveuglement, en particulier germano-français ou franco-allemand, sur Poutine.
Et c'est extrêmement bien documenté.
Ce qui permet une montée du poutinisme en France—
Évidemment.
Qui est absolument alarmante.
Oui, mais—
RT France, etc., ne se passe pas seulement, bon, qui a disparu aujourd'hui—
Ah non non, bien sûr.
Se passe pas seulement sur une initiative propre. Ça prend racine.
Mais comme je dis, la
sympathie
pro-russe de beaucoup de dirigeants français, et ça, c'est un peu au travers des familles politiques, pas chez les Verts, mais en tout cas, dans beaucoup de familles politiques qui ont dirigé ce pays, elle est manifeste.
Elle est manifeste. Alors bien sûr— Tout le monde n'est pas allé jusque-là où Marine Le Pen est allée, mais quand même, beaucoup étaient fiers de se faire prendre en photo avec Poutine.
Enfin, c'est Macron qui l'invite dans sa résidence de vacances et à Versailles. Enfin, j'ai dit : c'est d'un ridicule absolu, mais bon, peu importe.
Tout ça pour dire que la réaction initiale de l'Europe a été à la hauteur, enfin, presque à la hauteur, c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas osé se faire trop mal économiquement.
On s'est fait mal économiquement en prenant des sanctions, mais on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout dans le contrôle de ces sanctions qui ont été largement contournées par la Russie.
Donc, ça, c'est une chose. Et deux, maintenant, on sent une forme de fatigue. Et franchement—
Dans le financement des munitions logistiques.
La menace que la Russie présente pour l'Union européenne, elle est massive et non ambiguë. Donc, je vais dire, la guerre que mènent les Ukrainiens pour se défendre de Poutine, ben, ils la mènent, je vais dire, pour nous.
Pour nous, oui.
Et donc, si nous ne sommes pas capables de leur fournir ce dont ils ont besoin pour mener la guerre... Enfin, je veux dire, c'est les Ukrainiens qui sont au front.
C'est pas les Français, c'est pas les Belges, c'est pas les Italiens, c'est pas les Polonais, c'est les Ukrainiens qui sont au front.
Est-ce que vous défendriez l'idée de faire plus que leur fournir un soutien matériel et logistique ?
Non. Non, non. Il ne faut pas—
Est-ce que vous soutiendriez l'idée de monter au front ?
Il ne faut pas. Non, non, parce que, vous savez, un conflit entre l'OTAN et la Russie, on sait où ça commence, on sait pas où ça finit.
Donc là, non, il faut être prudent. Et donc tant que ça peut être contenu de la sorte, oui, mais alors, il faut pas lésiner sur le soutien financier et matériel que nous leur fournissons.
Oui, on se cache un petit peu derrière notre petit doigt quand même. Si on dit : les Ukrainiens font la guerre pour nous, on leur envoie nos munitions, on leur envoie notre argent.
Putain, on fait la guerre sans faire la guerre.
Oui, si vous voulez, mais qu'est-ce que vous préférez ? Qu'on fasse la guerre directe ?
Non, je— C'est pas une préférence, mais c'est—
Ma préférence, elle est claire. Ma préférence, elle est claire. En tout cas, eux ont la volonté de le faire et donc il faut qu'on leur donne les moyens de le faire.
Nous ne sommes pas cobelligérants, mais nous leur fournissons une profondeur stratégique.
Oui. Un financement—
Ça, c'est absolument crucial. Parce que face à la Russie, l'Ukraine toute seule, elle tiendrait jamais.
Et les États-Unis qui ont dû passer par un accord, je crois, avec la Grèce pour arriver à leur fournir un soutien logistique—
Là, c'est très inquiétant.
Sans le soutien des sénateurs qui sont peut-être un peu plus pro-russes et pro-Poutine.
Ben surtout, non, c'est pas les sénateurs sont pro-Poutine, les sénateurs sont pro-Trump. En fait, non.
Oui, oui. Ben, ben—
Les sénateurs américains font dans leur culotte face à Trump.
Oui.
Parce qu'encourir la colère de Trump, c'est pas bon pour le futur de leur carrière. En tout cas, c'est comme ça qu'ils le voient.
Et donc, et en effet, les républicains qui l'ont fait, ben ils sont plus au Sénat ou à la Chambre, notamment la fille de Dick Cheney, qui n'était pas un ange, on s'en fout. Donc—
Dick Cheney, oui.
Donc ça, c'est le problème qu'on a aux États-Unis. Et donc l'Union européenne doit réaliser que potentiellement, elle ne pourra plus compter que sur elle-même, hein.
C'est en effet la question que tout le monde se pose. Est-ce que aujourd'hui, tout dépend— Est-ce que la situation en Ukraine dépend entièrement, complètement de l'élection américaine ?
Ou bien est-ce que l'Europe peut—
L'Europe peut, si elle veut. L'Europe peut, si elle veut. L'effort qu'on consacre à l'Ukraine est assez modeste hein. Donc alors, il y a des limites de capacité.
Je veux dire, vous pouvez jeter de l'argent sur un problème. À un moment, ben si vous voulez des obus, il faut quand même des usines pour les fabriquer.
D'accord ? Et ça, il faut monter en capacité de production. Et je vous dis, je vous jure que pour un écolo, aller dire : il faut plus d'obus, c'est dur à dire quoi.
Mais désolé, on n'est pas dans un monde de bisounours. Donc à un moment, la seule chose que Poutine comprend, c'est la force.
C'est la seule chose. Donc l'effort qu'on doit consacrer est assez modeste. Enfin, on a adopté un plan à cinquante milliards à cinq ans.
Cinquante milliards, donc ça fait douze milliards et demi par an. Ça fait même pas un pour mille du PIB européen. Allez, les gars, franchement, c'est quand même pas, on demande pas la lune quoi.
Même si on triplait ça, ça serait encore des rires la virule. Donc allez, on est capable financièrement de le faire. Encore faut-il monter en capacité pour aider les Ukrainiens.
Et soit dit en passant, je pense qu'on n'évitera pas de renforcer la dissuasion que représente l'appareil militaire européen.
Alors là, il y a beaucoup d'économies à faire, tellement le truc est complètement désorganisé et dispersé. Et là, on touche aux égoïsmes nationaux en matière d'industrie de la défense.
Est-ce que vous êtes vous-même favorable à une défense européenne ?
Alors c'est une question compliquée. Comment dirais-je ? Je suis favorable à une Europe géopolitique. Et donc ça, ça suppose évidemment qu'au service de cette Europe géopolitique, il y ait un instrument militaire commun, fédéral.
Mais pour arriver là, il va y avoir du chemin. Parce que la première étape, qui est déjà extrêmement difficile, c'est de partager une vision géopolitique commune.
Ben c'est très clair que jusqu'à février deux mille vingt-deux, à l'Est, la principale menace qui était vue, c'était la Russie, mais pas du tout, pas du tout par les autres.
Et donc on n'a pas— Enfin, pour la France, c'était l'Afrique sahélienne.
Oui. Et encore plus pour les—
Et donc on n'a pas de vision commune de ce que représente notre environnement géostratégique. Ben ça, c'est la première étape.
La deuxième étape, c'est alors—
On a fait un pas dans cette direction avec les événements en Ukraine.
Oui, ça, c'est clair. Oui, mais on n'y est pas encore, hein. On n'y est pas encore. Non, c'est clair que Poutine, quelque part, nous a fait avancer dans cette direction-là.
Et si Trump devait être réélu, alors on en ferait un autre. Et là, j'ai envie de dire, c'est un peu la réponse du berger à la bergère.
Les Européens de l'Est nous ont dit : « Ah, on vous l'avait bien dit pour Poutine », mais ils ne jurent que par les États-Unis.
Si maintenant les États-Unis nous tournent le dos, les Français pourront leur dire : « Ben, on vous l'avait bien dit qu'on ne peut pas compter sur eux. »
Mais donc peut-être que le résultat des courses, ça sera : OK, maintenant, il faut qu'on se prenne en main. Et si on se prend en main, OK, comment est-ce qu'on voit notre environnement géopolitique
et quelle est la manière dont nous nous positionnons collectivement ?
Et ça, c'est d'abord des choses non militaires. C'est : comment est-ce qu'on se positionne vis-à-vis de notre voisinage direct ?
Alors, c'est les dossiers de coopération économique, c'est les dossiers asile migration, c'est tous les dossiers de voisinage.
Et puis, qu'est-ce qu'on met comme outil militaire au service de notre vision géostratégique ? Mais là va se poser une autre question qui est celle de la légitimation démocratique de l'action, de l'engagement de la force militaire.
Je m'explique. La force militaire, tout comme d'ailleurs les forces de police, sont des forces, donc ce sont des domaines régaliens où ce qui est en jeu, c'est la vie et la mort.
Donc si vous engagez une action militaire, inévitablement, vous allez avoir des cercueils qui rentrent. Donc des gens vont payer cette action de leur vie.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire ça sans une légitimation démocratique extrêmement forte. J'ai envie de dire que c'est le sujet qui doit appeler la plus forte légitimation démocratique des décisions.
Et là, on a des traditions en Europe qui sont mais totalement différentes. En France, un homme décide d'engager les forces armées françaises à l'étranger.
Il doit rendre compte, dans un délai, je crois d'un mois, à l'Assemblée nationale. Mais il décide. En Allemagne, y a pas un soldat de la Bundeswehr qui sort sans un vote du Bundestag, du Parlement allemand.
Et donc ces traditions-là, il va falloir s'accorder sur si on devait avoir une armée européenne, ben c'est qui qui légitime l'engagement et selon quelle procédure ?
Mais donc énormément de questions à régler, un consensus à trouver sur ces questions. Vous le disiez, c'est la question qui demande sans doute le plus de consensus démocratique de toutes les questions, la question de—
Tout à fait
...l'usage de la force. Les élections américaines, c'est cette année, c'est dans quelques mois. La stratégie historique russe du KGB, c'est semer la division, la discorde.
Ils le font très bien en ce moment en Europe. Donc trouver ce consensus, ré-arriver à résoudre ces questions, trouver des accords sur la question militaire me paraît très compliqué dans un temps court.
Oui, oui, ça, c'est clair. C'est pas la plus grande priorité. La première priorité là-dedans, c'est de rationaliser nos dépenses d'équipement
et d'avoir, et là-dessus, je suis plus français qu'Allemand, quand même, se donner les capacités d'être aussi autonome dans la production des équipements militaires dont on a besoin.
Désolé, mais on ne peut pas être perpétuellement dépendant. 'Fin, prenons la question des avions de combat et du F-35, qui est l'avion qui a été acheté par la plupart des pays européens, dont la Belgique.
Aujourd'hui, tout est dans le logiciel. Mais si vous n'avez pas les clés du logiciel ? 'Fin, Tesla peut brider votre voiture, mais les États-Unis, Lockheed Martin, peut brider votre F-35, hein.
'Fin, je veux dire, il y a une situation de dépendance. Même le seul partenaire de tout premier niveau du programme F-35 est le Royaume-Uni, ils n'ont pas accès à tous les codes.
C'est quand même une situation de dépendance extraordinaire. Et là, je pense que nous devrons trouver les chemins d'une moindre dépendance à l'égard des pays non européens.
Il y a un manque de souveraineté au niveau militaire, au niveau logistique.
Ça, c'est clair. Et rien que ça, c'est déjà des gros efforts, hein.
Mais donc, ça me semble très apparent dans votre réponse, toute la complexité dont il s'agit. Le temps qui se raccourcit de jour en jour vers l'élection potentielle de Donald Trump cette année
fait que ça paraît très compliqué pour l'Ukraine.
Ah, c'est sûr que si j'étais Volodymyr Zelensky, je serais pas à mon aise. Ça, c'est sûr. Parce que d'une part, une partie significative de l'aide, même si aujourd'hui l'Europe fait plus que les États-Unis, elle dépend de Washington.
Mais en termes matériels aussi, Washington est absolument crucial. Or, on l'a vu avec la contre-offensive de 2023, ils n'avaient pas assez d'équipements.
Donc déjà, ils en avaient pas assez et une des deux grosses sources pourrait se tarir. Mais ça, ça serait catastrophique.
Et donc ça, c'est le scénario catastrophe où finalement, Poutine obtient une victoire en Ukraine. Trump est réélu aux États-Unis.
Les politiques d'austérité poussent de plus en plus de monde en Europe dans les bras des nationaux populistes qui arrivent au gouvernement, comme c'est déjà le cas dans un certain nombre d'États membres.
Et très vite, l'Union européenne va tomber en déliquescence. Elle existera toujours, mais elle ne sera plus du tout un acteur.
Et donc la division, elle sera là. Et là, j'ai envie de dire à tous ceux qui parlent du déclin, etc. J'ai envie de leur dire : « Vous avez encore rien vu, hein ».
Parce que si ce scénario-là se passe, alors les Européens vont apprendre ce que c'est de devenir des nations totalement secondaires et vassales, dans le meilleur des cas, sur cette planète.
L'union, c'est la force-
Bien sûr
...très clairement au niveau européen. D'où la stratégie historique de Poutine, du KGB, la stratégie russe qui est semer la discorde, semer la division.
C'est ma prochaine question. Comment est-ce que... quel est votre regard sur l'efficacité de cette stratégie russe ?
Je me souviens, je pense que son nom, c'est Jan Slupski, au sein de la Commission européenne, qui est donc un spécialiste de la question russe au sein du service de politique étrangère de la Commission européenne.
Et je me rappelle avoir vu une vidéo d'une conférence de ce monsieur qui parlait donc des stratégies de désinformation, de discorde russe en Europe notamment.
Et dans la pièce même, il y avait des--
alors, je ne sais pas si c'était des agents russes, mais en tout cas, c'était des Russes
qui expliquaient que : « Mais non, mais non, ce n'est pas du tout ce que vous dites, ce n'est pas du tout la réalité » et qui expliquaient que la vérité n'était pas du tout
celle que disait le spécialiste en question.
Voilà, y a toujours ce truc de : on ne vit pas dans la même réalité quand on parle avec les poutinistes. C'est très clair.
Viktor Orbán n'est pas vraiment un poutiniste, mais un peu quand même.
Si, c'est... enfin, c'est un type qui admire les hommes forts.
Oui, oui.
Parce qu'en fait, il...
La culture de la virilité, finalement.
Oui. Et essentiellement, le business model est le même, puisqu'en fait, le but, c'est de se maintenir au pouvoir de manière permanente, de manière à s'enrichir sans borne.
Parce que c'est ça, hein. Je veux dire Orbán, Poutine et consorts, ce sont des gens qui s'en mettent plein les poches. Et ils savent très bien que s'ils sont plus au pouvoir, la poule aux œufs d'or sera plus là.
En tout cas, elle sera peut-être toujours là, mais pas pour eux.
Oui, et le plus grand soutien de Poutine sont des espèces d'aristocrates corrompus qui bénéficient très clairement de l'enrichissement de Poutine.
Mais voilà. Donc, attends, comment répondre à ça ? Moi, j'ai envie de dire que y a toujours eu de la désinformation, y a toujours eu des fake news, y a toujours eu des gens qui propageaient des rumeurs fausses, etc.
La question, c'est : est-ce que par notre action, nous faisons en sorte que le terreau soit fécond pour ce genre d'opération ou au contraire que le terreau soit stérile pour ce genre d'opération ?
Et c'est sûr que on paye de nouveau quarante ans de politique d'atomisation de nos sociétés, de divisions, d'inégalités qui ont donné à beaucoup de nos concitoyens le sentiment de ne compter pour rien.
Et ça, c'est le terreau fertile. C'est si je compte pour rien, mais c'est qu'en fait, tout ça est un grand complot et on l'a vu à l'occasion du COVID.
Tout ça est un grand complot de nos dirigeants. Et finalement, ben Poutine, il dénonce nos dirigeants, donc il est de notre côté quoi.
Et donc ça, ça appelle à une action patiente, mais déterminée, de réduction des inégalités, de... comment est-ce que je dirais ?
Si je disais, je sais pas, à un échantillon représentatif de mille Belges, je leur lis l'article deux du traité qui liste les valeurs de l'Union, à commencer par la dignité humaine, c'est la toute première.
Si je leur demandais : est-ce que vous avez le sentiment dans votre vie que ces valeurs sont respectées ou pas, je serais curieux de voir ce qu'ils répondent.
Mais ce que je crois, c'est qu'il y a vraiment une défiance énorme de nos concitoyens à l'égard de l'action publique, parce que l'impression qu'ils ont et qui, malheureusement, n'est pas totalement à tort,
c'est que les décisions qui sont prises par les organes politiques, que ce soit au niveau européen, national,
sont des décisions qui ne vont pas dans le sens de l'intérêt général, mais qui favorisent des intérêts particuliers.
Et la réalité, si vous lisez Piketty, Zucman et consorts, c'est en tout cas, si on mesure l'intérêt par l'argent, c'est clair que depuis la révolution néolibérale, l'argent s'est concentré de plus en plus.
Et donc ça, forcément, c'est le fruit de décisions politiques.
Oui.
C'est le fruit de décisions politiques.
Vous parlez du terrain économique qui, voilà, qui bénéficie à la discorde, qui bénéficie à Vladimir Poutine.
Un autre axe qui est très fascinant, c'est la question de ce que les partisans de Poutine appellent le wokisme.
Et on voit la réaction viscérale que ça crée, mais pas seulement chez les pro-poutinistes, mais même de manière générale dans la population.
Même au sein, ben j'ai entendu des présentateurs de la RTBF reprendre ce terme de wokisme.
Oui, mais ça, c'est de nouveau des néologismes qui sont utilisés pour dénoncer en fait toutes les évolutions sociétales de la société.
Des termes finalement qui viennent de l'extrême droite et d'une nation populiste.
Oui, évidemment.
Mais qui, c'est fascinant, on en arrive au stade où ces termes-là, ces néologismes-là arrivent à s'insérer même dans-
Dans la conversation commune.
De journalistes historiques parfaitement historiquement raisonnables, de la RTBF, etc.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait, mais donc, je rappelle que ce terme signifie
être éveillé, éveillé en fait à des discriminations, que ce soit les discriminations de genre, les discriminations basées sur la couleur de peau, sur la religion, sur l'orientation sexuelle et que sais-je encore.
Et de nouveau, si on est fidèle à l'idéal des Lumières, tous les êtres humains ont
la vocation et le droit de mener une existence conforme à la dignité, quelle que soit leur origine, quelle que soit leur croyance, quel que soit leur genre, quelle que soit leur orientation sexuelle, etc.
Et donc c'est un combat tout à fait noble, c'est la poursuite du combat des Lumières. Là où je pense la gauche s'est un peu égarée en chemin,
c'est qu'elle a cru,
en tout cas une partie de la gauche, et je dirais en particulier la gauche social-démocrate qui a quelque part abandonné en ralliant la pensée néolibé... enfin pas la pensée, c'est pas une pensée, je le répète, c'est une idéologie,
c'est un ensemble de croyances, mais qui a rallié, en ralliant la doxa néolibérale et donc les réformes de structures
qui ont en fait affaibli l'État social, affaibli la négociation collective, etc.
Ils se sont dit : bon, on va compenser ça en défendant les minorités. Mais le combat pour la justice sociale ne se résume pas à la somme des combats de défense de toutes les minorités.
Je veux dire, un homme blanc ouvrier d'ArcelorMittal qui perd son job à cause de choix qui mènent à la désindustrialisation, n'a pas moins droit à une existence conforme à la dignité
que n'importe qui d'autre et que n'importe quel membre de n'importe quelle minorité.
Oui. Je vais peut-être essayer de formuler ma question autrement. Le patriarcat est présent depuis des millénaires. Il est très installé dans nos cultures, dans nos croyances, dans nos fonctionnements.
J'ai l'impression, je me pose parfois la question de savoir si,
remettre en question ce patriarcat,
vouloir le faire, oui, le remettre en question, le faire disparaître, ne crée pas des réactions, des réponses plus viscérales, plus défensives encore que quand on parle de remettre en question des systèmes économiques.
Ça, je sais pas. Je n'ai pas d'éléments pour répondre à cette question-là. Maintenant, il doit être remis en question de nouveau.
Ce qu'il faut dire, c'est que Vladimir Poutine bénéficie très clairement de ces réactions viscérales quand on parle de remettre en question le patriarcat, remettre en question l'oppression des minorités sexuelles, etc.
On voit des personnes qui sont très très énervées et très agitées, face à cette mise en question-là et qui en finissent par récupérer ces néologismes de l'extrême droite.
Oui, bien sûr. Je veux dire, le dernier n'est pas chose, Bardella, qui s'y est mis aussi. Donc...
Qui explique par exemple que les écologistes sont, ont leur place dans l'enfer de Dante. Enfin, c'est, c'est très particulier.
Oui, mais bon.
À quel point ils diabolisent.
Honnêtement dit, ça m'impressionne pas. Mais ça montre aussi qu'on subit des reculs aujourd'hui. Je veux dire, rien que l'égalité homme-femme, on peut dire que les combats sont pas gagnés.
Je veux dire, quand on voit ce qui s'est passé en Pologne, quand on voit encore les discriminations au boulot aujourd'hui, les différences salariales, etc.
Ça reste quand même des réalités. Donc le combat pour l'égalité, il est toujours pas fini hein, et donc il faut pas lâcher là-dessus, il faut absolument pas lâcher là-dessus.
Mais, comme je dis, c'est toujours au nom du combat pour l'égalité, pour l'égale dignité de tous les êtres humains, point barre.
Je dis bien de tous les êtres humains. Et c'est pas la revanche de certains êtres humains contre d'autres êtres humains.
Et donc il faut pas tomber dans ce panneau-là. Ce que nous menons, c'est un combat pour l'égalité, ça n'est pas une guerre revanchiste.
C'est pas la même chose. C'est pas la même chose.
Pour revenir sur la Russie, ce matin, les services de renseignement espagnols ont accusé la Russie d'avoir envoyé des assassins à Alicante pour neutraliser un défecteur.
Donc c'est encore un petit peu plus loin dans les stratégies d'ingérence russe, puisque ce serait... Théoriquement, c'est difficile de commenter à ce stade, mais ce serait des assassins russes qui ont agi en Europe.
Bah ouais, et alors ? Il y a rien de neuf sous le soleil, non ? Enfin, je veux dire, Trotski s'est fait assassiner par le NKVD au Mexique.
C'était quand ? En 1940, je ne sais plus. Je veux dire que la Russie tsariste, que la Russie soviétique et que la Russie actuelle envoient des assassins à l'extérieur, c'est quand même rien de nouveau sous le soleil, non ?
Est-ce qu'il faut y répondre ? Ou est-ce que...
Est-ce qu'il faut envoyer des assassins en Russie, non ça je comprends pas. On essaie d'agir selon des méthodes civilisées.
L'usage de la force sur le sol européen pourrait justifier l'usage de la force sur le sol russe.
Ça, enfin, je crois qu'alors il faut arrêter ces gens. Il faut arrêter ces gens. Dans certains cas, on a réussi, mais dans d'autres pas.
Et donc il faut arrêter de faire preuve de complaisance aussi à l'égard de...
De passivité.
Oui, ça, je dois dire, il faut serrer les boulons de ce côté-là. Maintenant, bon, la guerre de l'ombre, c'est un truc pas facile à appréhender, hein, donc...
Pour revenir à la question d'origine, quelles sont les réponses qu'on doit fournir à la stratégie poutiniste de semer la discorde, de, voilà, de semer les graines qui vont être récupérées.
Construire l'unité. Rendre le terrain de nos sociétés stérile pour ce genre d'initiative. Si je me sens bien dans ma société, si je me sens pris en compte par ma société, moi, il y a un type qui peut vociférer à Moscou, ça me laisse froid.
Si par contre, j'ai depuis des années l'impression d'être laissé pour compte et que ce type-là à Moscou dénonce toute une série de maux dont je m'estime être la victime, ben je le considère comme un allié.
Ça, c'est la situation dans laquelle on est. Donc il y a pas de réponse facile à ça. Il y a pas de réponse immédiate à ça.
Mais en tout cas, il faut certainement pas ramener de nouveau l'austérité dans nos pays.
Donc votre réponse, c'est finalement, c'est qu'il faut une politique de gauche, une politique qui va moins écraser.
Une politique qui inclut et pas une politique qui exclut.
Voilà. Donc vous blâmez la politique économique historique néolibérale. Et ce qui est fascinant, c'est que de leur côté-
Qui n'est pas propriété des libéraux, hein.
Oui. Et ce qui est fascinant, c'est que... oui, puisque social-démocrate, tout ça, mais... Ce qui est fascinant, c'est que de leur côté, la droite va expliquer que c'est la faute des wokistes, c'est la faute de la gauche.
Mais quand ils veulent, quand ils veulent, les gars, moi, je leur dis : dites, si je reprends les quarante ou quarante-cinq dernières années ou cinquante, peu importe hein,
la taille des Verts, la taille du PPE, la taille des socio-démocrates, la taille des libéraux et surtout le nombre d'années au pouvoir, c'est quoi l'effet ?
C'est pas très crédible, en effet.
Donc, vous nous créditez d'une
influence extrêmement forte sur vos politiques. En fait, en fait, vous nous reconnaissez comme vos maîtres à penser puisque vous nous attribuez tout ce qui va mal dans la société alors qu'on n'a quasi pas été au pouvoir.
Donc ça veut dire en fait, vous n'écoutiez que nous. Vous n'écoutiez que nous et vous faisiez ce qu'on vous demandait. Aujourd'hui, vous dites : merde, on n'aurait pas dû écouter les Verts.
Allez, franchement, give me a break, comme on dit en bon français. Arrêtez vos salades quoi. Assumez vos responsabilités.
Le gros de l'état actuel de l'Union européenne, c'est d'abord le produit des politiques du PPE, des socialistes et des libéraux.
Ça, c'est juste un fait mesurable.
Vous incluez les socialistes dans, dans...
Oh mais évidemment.
Et je pense qu'ils portent une responsabilité énorme dans l'augmentation du vote de l'extrême droite parce que quand ils ont abandonné le combat pour la justice sociale,
ben quelque part, ils ont poussé leurs électeurs dans les bras de l'extrême droite.
Si je suis un électeur traditionnel socialiste et que je vote socialiste et que j'ai des politiques néolibérales, ben, je vais essayer autre chose.
Ce qui passait avec le mandat de François Hollande en France, par exemple.
Ben oui. Ben ça a commencé bien avant ça, mais...
C'était particulièrement évident le score qu'il a fait au début et à la fin.
Regardez les politiques de Gerhard Schröder en Allemagne et c'est un social-démocrate. Enfin allez, ça suffit quoi. Pour pas vous parler des travaillistes britanniques.
Donc non, ils portent une responsabilité écrasante dans ce qui s'est passé.
Ils n'ont pas tenu bon. Et encore aujourd'hui, je vais dire, pour avoir été dans la salle de négociation des règles budgétaires européennes, vous auriez dû voir la négociatrice socialiste.
Mais c'était une capitulation sans condition. C'était une capitulation. Je lui ai demandé à un moment : mais c'est quoi ta ligne rouge ?
Elle m'a dit : c'est d'avoir un deal à tout prix. C'est-à-dire un deal sans ligne rouge, puisque ma ligne rouge, c'est d'avoir un deal.
Donc, elle était prête à accepter n'importe quoi. Elle n'était pas prête à envisager le non-accord. Je veux dire, si vous rentrez dans la salle de négociation
en disant : le non-accord est inenvisageable pour moi, ben ça vous mène à accepter un accord à n'importe quelle condition.
C'est une capitulation.
Ben oui. Et ça, c'est encore aujourd'hui. Et le gros du groupe socialiste, enfin, des leaders socialistes comme Pedro Sanchez, premier ministre espagnol,
Costa, enfin non, Antonio Costa ne sera plus premier ministre portugais, mais Paolo Gentiloni, le commissaire européen,
à l'économie, qui est
le père de ces règles budgétaires.
Tous ces socialistes appellent à l'adoption de ces règles budgétaires, hein. À l'adoption, pas à l'abstention, à l'adoption.
Ils continuent. Donc comme s'ils n'avaient toujours pas compris que c'est eux qui avaient envoyé leurs électeurs dans les bras de l'extrême droite.
C'est à se demander : mais qu'est-ce qu'il leur faut quoi ?
Philippe Lamberts, on a abordé beaucoup de questions ensemble. Les questions énergétiques, questions géopolitiques, questions de l'enseignement même, la question des agriculteurs, question du poutinisme.
Plein d'enjeux, la question de l'austérité, plein d'enjeux qui sont, mais extrêmement importants. Je ne sais pas si on a déjà eu une élection européenne ces vingt dernières années où les enjeux étaient plus importants qu'ils ne sont aujourd'hui.
Et c'est aujourd'hui que vous choisissez de ne pas vous représenter.
Exact. Enfin, c'est pas aujourd'hui. J'ai choisi il y a longtemps.
Oui, c'est cette, voilà, c'est cette année. On va parler à présent un petit peu de vous, puisqu'on n'a pas encore fait. Qu'est-ce qui justifie ce choix ?
Mais en contrat avec ceux qui ont soutenu ma candidature. J'ai dit d'emblée, quand j'ai brigué l'Europe, ce serait l'Europe et pas autre chose.
Et donc, il n'était pas question pour moi d'aller voir un autre niveau de pouvoir. Ça, chacun a son charisme, j'ai envie de dire, mais moi, c'est ici que ça se passe et c'est ici que je suis bon.
Deux, j'ai dit que ce serait l'Europe et pour deux ou trois mandats. C'est vrai qu'au premier mandat, je disais d'emblée : j'en veux un deuxième.
J'espère pouvoir faire dix ans et pas simplement cinq. Et quinze si c'est possible et si ça se met. Mais pas, pas, pas vingt.
Et donc j'ai dit d'emblée ça. J'ai dit ça il y a quinze ans, je l'ai répété. J'ai dit : ça serait deux ou trois mandats.
Alors certains avaient cru entendre, ça serait deux et pas plus. Non, j'avais toujours dit deux ou trois. Et c'est vrai qu'à la moitié du deuxième mandat, j'ai hésité.
J'ai hésité à poursuivre pour un troisième mandat tellement j'avais l'impression de tout le temps ramer à contre-courant.
C'était la commission Juncker après la commission Barroso II. Rien n'allait dans le bon sens et voilà. Donc à un moment-
Mais expliquez-moi, pourquoi pas un quatrième aujourd'hui ?
Parce que je trouve qu'avoir fait quinze ans au Parlement, dont dix à la tête du groupe, c'est suffisant. Je veux dire, c'est un chapitre de ma vie professionnelle.
Je trouve même avoir pu exercer, avoir eu, honnêtement dit, l'honneur d'exercer la présidence du groupe des Verts au Parlement européen pendant dix ans, c'est bien, il faut pas quinze.
Enfin, donc bien sûr, j'aurais pu revenir, j'aurais pu revenir au Parlement européen comme backbencher, comme législateur du rang.
J'en suis capable de faire ça, mais peut-être que je suis aussi capable de contribuer à la transformation de la société à un autre endroit.
Comme ? Comme lequel ?
Oh, ça, on verra bien. Ça-
Vous n'avez aucune idée de où vous serez en juillet, monsieur Lamberts.
Ça peut être plein de choses. D'abord, ça sera pas juillet. Ça sera pas juillet parce que-- donc ça peut être, allez-
Vous allez prendre des vacances ?
Pardon ?
Ah ça, de toute façon, ça, je vous le dis. Mais ça peut être continuer en politique au niveau européen, mais dans un autre rôle.
Ça peut être retourner dans le business, j'en viens. J'ai quand même travaillé vingt-deux ans dans le business et travailler dans une entreprise qui est dans la transition,
c'est-à-dire dans sa transition ou qui contribue à la transition de nos sociétés, ben ça peut être passionnant.
Dans un think tank ou enseigner, c'est toutes des choses que j'aime faire.
Oui. Plein de possibilités. Vous n'êtes pas obligé de me dire aujourd'hui où vous serez dans quelques mois.
Non, mais c'est pas décidé. Donc-
Ce n'est pas décidé.
Non. Honnêtement dit, mon focus maintenant, c'est de finir, d'aider à la campagne, parce que ça, je vais faire. Là où on me demande, j'irai, j'irai aider.
Vous êtes là pour ça aujourd'hui, oui.
Parce que les Verts doivent vraiment jouer le match de leur vie et on doit jouer au niveau Champions League quoi. C'est là qu'on doit jouer.
Et pour l'instant, je trouve qu'on n'y est pas encore. Les élections sont dans quatre mois. On a encore un peu de temps, mais il faut cravacher quoi, parce qu'il faut se hisser à la hauteur des enjeux et être la surprise du scrutin.
Tout le monde nous donne pour moitié mort. Eh ben, je pense qu'on va leur montrer qu'on a encore du poil de la bête quoi.
Donc qu'on n'est pas, qu'il faut pas nous passer par profit et perte si vite. Voilà, donc ça, c'est l'objectif.
Et puis après, en effet, j'ai envie d'un peu lever le pied avant de décider ce que je vais faire de la suite. On verra, mais...
On verra, on verra. Donc bon, le futur, vous l'avez dit, on verra. Vous n'avez pas encore pris de décision ?
Non, non.
Ces quinze dernières années, quel bilan est-ce que vous faites de votre action en politique ?
Ben ça, j'ai envie de dire, c'est un peu aux autres de dire ce qu'ils en pensent. Moi, personnellement, je pense avoir apporté ma pierre-
Oui.
À la crédibilisation de l'écologie politique comme une force alternative et comme une force de transformation.
Qu'est-ce que vous retenez comme vos plus grands accomplissements ?
Oh écoutez, comme législateur, c'est clairement la négociation sur les règles bancaires pendant mon premier mandat. Mais après, j'ai plus été un législateur, j'ai été un chef de groupe.
Et là, ben c'est le fait d'avoir su porter la parole. Parce qu'en fait, la présidence du groupe, c'est à la fois un rôle de management.
Ben bon, ça, je veux dire, c'est un peu ordinaire. C'est un rôle d'accoucheur de convergence, c'est-à-dire de maintien de la cohésion du groupe.
Et ça, je crois que j'ai quand même pas mal fait. Quand je vois la manière dont ce groupe a voté pendant les dix ans où je l'ai présidé, je pense que j'étais un facteur de cohésion.
Et puis, c'est la communication externe. C'est-à-dire, je suis une des figures du groupe et je pense avoir donné de l'écologie politique.
N'oubliez pas que je succédais à Dani Cohn-Bendit, qui, entre-temps, nous a quittés pour les sirènes du macronisme, mais c'était quand même pas n'importe qui dans l'histoire de l'écologie politique.
Je pense que je n'ai pas à rougir de la manière dont j'ai assumé la succession dans ma fonction d'expression publique.
Je crois que j'ai apporté à la fois de la crédibilité à la famille que je représente et, je dirais, de la désirabilité, dans le sens où je pense pas avoir été un repoussoir-
Intéressant. Donc le bilan que vous faites, c'est finalement plutôt une question d'image et de communication en tant que chef de groupe.
Ben comme chef de groupe, c'est quand même un très gros morceau de votre rôle.
Oui, OK.
Voilà, comme je vous dis, il y a trois piliers à ça. Il y a le management, il y a la cohésion et il y a l'expression publique.
Et voilà. Et j'ai travaillé aussi, et ça, c'est peut-être un truc que je garderai toujours,
au renforcement du soubassement scientifique et idéologique du projet de l'écologie politique
en commanditant des études, en organisant la-- ça, c'est vrai que ça a été un moment de grande fierté, la,
la deuxième édition, enfin la première aussi, mais la deuxième a été un succès vraiment incroyable,
de la conférence post-croissance au mois de mai 2023 ici au Parlement européen, de rassembler des députés, des commissaires de cinq familles politiques différentes sur un agenda qui est quand même en rupture avec le modèle économique dominant.
Ben, on en rêvait, mais on l'a fait quoi. Alors c'est sûr, c'est juste une étape dans un chemin de transition, mais ça a été quand même une étape qui était un moment de grande mobilisation, je trouve.
Il fallait être dans la salle, c'était quelque chose quoi. Voilà, ça, c'est des moments de fierté, évidemment, que j'emmène avec moi dans, à l'étape suivante quoi.
Des regrets aussi ?
Des regrets, oui, peut-être-- bon, ça m'est pas arrivé souvent, mais d'avoir voté contre la loi climat au niveau du Parlement européen.
On est passé d'un objectif de moins quarante pour cent d'émissions en 2030 à un objectif de moins cinquante-cinq. Alors, c'est sûr que la science dit : « Ça devait être moins soixante-cinq.
» La majorité du groupe a voulu qu'on vote contre pour ça parce que c'était pas assez. Mais ma tradition a toujours été de dire : « On prend tous les progrès possibles et puis on continue de se battre.
» Et si on a dit non à quelque chose qui était un progrès manifeste par rapport au statu quo, et ça, je crois qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire.
Ça arrive de faire parfois des trucs pareils, et quelque part, de ne voir que l'arbre et pas la forêt quoi. Voilà, donc ça, c'est, bon-
Ce sont des comptes à rendre.
On n'en a pas commis beaucoup des comme ça, mais c'est arrivé. Voilà, j'aurais préféré que ce ne soit pas le cas.
Très bien. Philippe Lamberts, merci beaucoup. On est arrivé au bout de ces Septante Minutes. Et on se retrouve très bientôt pour un prochain épisode.
Merci. Je tiens à remercier l'équipe de la Voxbox du Parlement européen pour leur aide pour enregistrer et produire cet épisode.
Ça a vraiment été une superbe expérience. Je remercie aussi le pôle communication du Parlement européen qui m'a donné les accès au studio radio et qui m'a invité à Strasbourg il y a quelques semaines.
Si vous avez l'occasion un jour dans votre vie d'assister à une séance plénière, croyez-moi, c'est une expérience qui vaut le détour.
J'ai vraiment adoré. J'en parlais en intro, il y a un épisode qui n'a pas pu être publié il y a deux semaines. J'ai eu l'opportunité de rencontrer Jean-Luc Crucke,
ancien ministre du Budget wallon, qui a quitté le Mouvement réformateur de Georges-Louis Bouchez pour lancer Les Engagés avec Maxime Prévot.
Un entretien riche, très intéressant, qui revenait sur le contexte belge et l'actualité récente. Je le remercie encore d'avoir accepté de se livrer.
C'est la première fois que ça m'arrive en cinq ans. C'est absolument cauchemardesque, mais on dirait bien que le micro de Jean-Luc Crucke n'a pas enregistré sa voix et tout indique que c'est moi qui ai merdé.
Je continue à essayer de sauver cette interview, sauver cet enregistrement. Vous comprenez bien que c'est un petit peu de la nécromancie et du bricolage à ce stade, mais je ne démords pas et je vous tiens au courant.
Quoi qu'il arrive, une chose est certaine, on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un épisode avec François De Smet, président de Défi. À très bientôt.